hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
welcome back to a q and a sunday i've
not done one of these videos in a few
weeks and i kind of feel bad i know i've
been asked loads of questions by my
subscribers and right now i'm gonna be
banging through the questions john
benton willy kelly the drone operator
craig coats sahil muttani there's loads
and loads of subscribers they've been
asking me questions about property and
i've been so so so busy i haven't had a
chance to answer but right now i am
going to be answering all your property
investment questions as best i can and
also if you're a subscriber and you want
to
find out something about property maybe
you've been struggling with something or
there's something that's been bothering
you a little bit or you've been
challenged maybe you've been out to a
viewing and you're not sure whether the
house is a good deal or a bad deal
whether you're overseas in the united
states of america australia ireland
wales scotland england i'd love to hear
your questions so go ahead comment your
question below and i'll do my best to
answer um also
i've been working on so many real estate
deals recently and some bigger
development deals um i just feel excited
i feel really excited i hope you feel
excited too if you are excited if you
enjoy my youtube channel please do me a
massive favor and go ahead and smash the
like button it doesn't cost you a penny
to do it and it really really helps the
channel out so please do go ahead hit
the like button and then also start
commenting your questions below i've had
an influx of new subscribers recently so
i don't know where those guys have come
from but if you're new on the channel
welcome if you're not a subscriber yet
subscribe to the channel let's see what
we've got so someone says
john benton says
my question is as follows
very formal see how can you not respond
to such a formal question as john
benton's what investment strategy would
you recommend for someone wanting to
build a property portfolio currently one
property owned
that has a high monthly income
roughly
25 000 pounds per
month from net profit from a current
business wow 25 grand a month net profit
to invest in property that is awesome
congratulations john i don't feel that
any other person in your position
has answered a similar question so it'd
be great to hear your advice
um well firstly john it depends on what
you're trying so there's two types of
income okay there's fast pounds which is
what you're making you've got a business
i don't know what the business is but
it's trade it's trading income it's
giving you fast active income and then
there's a second type of income which is
slow pound passive income now it sounds
to me like you're in the absolute
perfect situation
whereby you've got your business
your time by the way nearly all of your
time should be focused on your business
generating that quick cash
every month and then with that money
that you make
i would say that you should put that
into property investment it's going to
be hands-off slow income um my advice to
you if you're making 25 grand a month i
mean if you were doing really little
tiny deals like you were buying little
brrs or little investments of the far
north of the country or in south wales
for example you could literally be
buying a property every single
month
now that might be really attractive
a lot of people might say to do that buy
a house every month but here's the thing
buying a house once a month
also means having to fill out paperwork
solicitors legal
mortgage applications
it's quite a pain and then you having to
deal with all the tenant moving in and
getting the managements up so what i
would probably do if i were you is i
would i would do buy refurbished
refinance but i would do it on bigger
type deals so maybe um you know every 10
months with 250 grand go ahead and use
that 250 grand to buy maybe like um a
big commercial unit which you can then
convert into residential units or maybe
a piece of land that you can build on or
a pub that you can convert and do bigger
deals that are more hands-off because a
big deal on a small deal takes just as
much time so you've got your slow wealth
generation stuff going on over here and
then you've got a quick trading pound
here so that's probably what i'd look at
i hope you found that helpful and if
there's a follow-up question go ahead
and ask below right who's next
will kelly i felt the whole table my
wife always tells me don't bang on the
table because it makes the whole video
shake so um maybe instead of me banging
on the table maybe you could just go
ahead and smash that like button for me
we need some energy go do that right now
uh will kelly says my question is during
your career
what has been your biggest hurdle to
overcome
hmm i would say my biggest hurdle well
in my career has been patience has been
having to deal with people being slow
that counts and right now my biggest
pain in my freaking backside is the
council's taking forever to give me
planning permission to do stuff that's
so
what i find really frustrating is when
the ball is out of my court and property
can be very very slow
so waiting for solicitors waiting for
the council to give planning permission
that has been the biggest pain in my
backside from day one of starting a
property in 2009
right up till today
the drone operator
says i have some cash on the way from a
work injury claim and i'm hoping to
employ the buy refurbish refinance
strategy
however how likely would it be to get an
initial mortgage and then a remortgage
while being a student and not being
employed right now
great question the journal operating off
clearly very smart because you're
thinking about the long call so
when you get a bar refurbished finance
deal
the
initially financing it that is not gonna
be probably an issue for you because the
initially financing it you're just gonna
you're gonna buy cash right you're gonna
buy it with the money that you've got
from the work injury you're going to top
up the difference with maybe a bridging
loan
that's not going to be an issue the hard
bit is going to be the refinance at the
end
if you're a student and you've got no
income um
that's going to be the challenging part
so what i would do if i were you is i
would firstly
speak to a mortgage advisor tell them
your situation find out what kind of buy
to let more could you qualify
let's say you would qualify for
a small buy to let mortgage anything
less than 150 grand
let's say i don't know if you would but
bear in mind as well
mortgage lenders when they're giving you
money for a buy to let
they care less about your income as they
do about the
rentability of the house so you're not
going to be able to get finance
a mortgage on a hmo probably or a um you
know something big or especially if it's
a big hmo commercial property maybe not
but if it's a small little bite you
might
so i would say find out first what you
can get a mortgage on and then buy
the rundown version
cash with your work money with your with
your um you know your injury claim money
and bridging finance and then when you
push the value up then get the refinance
but make sure you you go in knowing that
you're having a plan i hope that makes
sense if it doesn't ask again ask
another question or maybe consider
coming down i'm running a training
program called the property millionaire
intensive sounds a little bit of um an
interesting title that's because if you
want to be a property millionaire
ultimately the fastest way to do that is
fast pound slow bands you can have a
trading business as deal sourcing rent
to rent getting cash but then it's all
about that buyer refurbished refinance
baby and that's what we're gonna be
teaching um so the drone operator or
anybody else i have got um limited
tickets i know a few of them were sold
out now a few of the venues but
click the link in the description and
i'll do my best to help at the program
okay craig
coats says
if you i've just started my journey and
posting it to social media and oh my
i don't blaspheme sorry i'm a christian
as you say there can be a million
different excuses to not get started and
loads of people are commenting on these
excuses
things like wrong time to buy samuel's a
scammer deals too risky
but i'm with you where there's a will
there's a way
financial freedom is my aim
okay craig well firstly massive
congratulations for stepping out um
listen if
if you imagine if you are in a room
filled with obese people filled with
really fat people okay and and and
they're all comfortable and they're all
fat and they all love eating pizza all
day long and then one of them goes you
know what guys
i think i'm going to get slim i think
i'm going to get a six pack i think
what all the fat people probably going
to say sorry if this is a bit of a crude
analogy i'm allowed to joke about
overweight people because i'm a little
bit overweight myself apparently um so
so so what are
what are they gonna say they're gonna
say oh six-pack that's that that's uh
that's never gonna happen they're gonna
say oh just come and enjoy a pizza or
not just with anything if you're a
smoker if if you if you if you're in a
group of smokers and you've got a man i
think i'm going to quit i'm like oh i
know it's tough anymore come on i have
another one i'll quit next year and it's
the exact same with finances if you say
i'm going to get into property i'm going
to become wealthy i want to become
financially free if you're hanging
around people that are in jobs aren't
financially free aren't millionaires
they're struggling with money they're
probably going oh don't worry forget it
just stay in the club stay in the broke
club man it's not that bad come on man
come on craig and i think and they'll
say things you know oh it's risky you
know and they'll come with all the
reasons all the excuses under the sun as
to why it's not possible why you
shouldn't do it
so what i'm what i'll say is
just make sure that you're surrounding
yourself if you want to become
successful in property with people that
are
in property already people that are
succeeding in property so that's that's
my best advice okay sahil says
could you go over the legal side of
things in rent to rent
sure thing so biggest thing in rent to
rent is getting permission permission
permission permission permission you
need to get permission from the landlord
you need to get you need to make sure
the landlord's got permission off the
mortgage lender you need to if it's an
apartment block and it's leasehold you
need to get permission to do off the
freeholder if you're going through an
agent you need to get permission from
the agent how do you get permission
by explaining it properly and
articulating what you're doing properly
if you articulate it properly to the
mortgage lender they'll probably give
you permission to do it and they'll give
you a a a letter of consent if you
explain it properly to the agent if you
explain it properly to the landlord
they'll give you permission so
i think the biggest thing is making sure
that you can articulate rental rents
properly and you can show the value and
make sure you get the relevant
permission don't try and do it sneakily
behind closed doors do it upfront it's a
proper business and get the right
contracts that's the biggest advice i
can give you on regiment talking legally
steve c says
i'd love to get started in property but
i'm 53
a young one and i don't have money to
shout home about but i here you can buy
then let out and let the tenant
basically buy your property for you any
advice would be helpful
you can do that steve
steve
when you understand how to make money in
property if you're 53 or 35 or 15
the world is your oyster baby um yeah
like if you look steve if you buy a
property let's say you buy a house for
200 000 pounds and you put down a small
deposit and then the mortgage
you're going to have the mortgage
payments right let's say the mortgage
payments are 500 a month
half of that is interest
and the other half of that is repayment
and over 25 years you're going to slowly
pay back the mortgage and then after 25
years let's say
you own the house outright with no debt
well if you buy the house as long as the
tenants are paying more than 500 pounds
a month for it
let's say the tenants are paying 800
pounds a month forever which is average
rent
then the tenants are going to be paying
your interest
paying down your mortgage
and paying you a monthly profit as well
so it's brilliant you just need to make
sure you're buying the right area also
you want to make sure you're getting
capital appreciation and make sure you
don't have any problems with the tenants
so you're going to make sure you have
the right management systems up in place
but that's absolutely right right last
question zach woodbury says
if you had to start over with 15 000
pounds presuming you had done your
course and educated yourself which
strategy would you start with and why
rent to rent why because
if you control the property instead of
buy it you can make just the same rent
from it you can make just the same
profit if not more from it so i think if
i just 15 grand i'd take control of a
few properties because let's face it man
if i had 15 grand and i put that down to
just buy one house
what's that gonna do
i'm gonna have to wait 20 years
to pay the mortgage now or i'm gonna i'm
gonna make
100 200 quid a month profit
it's hardly life-changing whereas if
i've got 15 grand if i can get a few
rental rents
and put them on service accommodation on
airbnb i can get a nice income from that
every month and i'm going to save some
of that income and then i'm going to
slowly invest it into property to build
my own portfolio but i think that's what
i'll do so
guys i hope you've enjoyed this video
hope this has given you a little bit of
light-hearted but informational content
around how you can become financially
free property because here's the thing
all the stuff i'm talking about
it might be a bit of fun or yeah get
your first deal but this will actually
change your life financially if you let
it so here's the 2022 go kick some ass
drop your comments and questions below
and i'll see you next time